tenemos que factorizar menos 4 de
cuadrada menos 12 tm 9 y lo primero que
quiero que te des cuenta es que estos
términos no tienen un factor común claro
4 y 2 se tiene un factor común que por
cierto es 4 pero 9 no entra entre ellos
no ha habido si tiene un factor común
que es el 3 pero pero el 49 entre en
ellos entonces lo primero que se me
ocurre pensar es que menos 1 es un
factor común porque todos tienen signo
negativo y si yo factor hizo el menos 1
me va a quedar 4 de cuadrada más 12
temas 9 a continuación lo que quiero que
veas es que qué pasa si esta expresión
de puerta sólida es un binomio al
cuadrado perfecto y ojo voy a pensar que
tal vez sea un binomio cuadrado perfecto
no forzosamente tiene que ser un binomio
al cuadrado perfecto y tal vez para
factorizar esto tendremos que pensar en
agrupación o en cualquier otra forma de
factorización pero bueno a mí se me
ocurre que es un binomio al cuadrado
perfecto porque 4 t cuadrado tiene raíz
cuadrada exacta y 9 también lo tiene así
que que me quedaba de multiplicar a más
ve por más si yo tuviera a más de
programas b pues esto es a más del
cuadrado es un binomio cuadrado
y el resultado que me quedaba de
multiplicar este por este era a cuadrada
ahora me da a cuadrada después me
quedaba a ver después me quedaba también
ave ave o vea es lo mismo y al final me
quedaba be cuadrada más b cuadrado y te
das cuenta aquí tengo un ave y otro ave
por lo tanto puedo simplificar esta
expresión
además haberme quedado dos veces eventos
al final me queda a cuadrada más dos
veces sabe más be cuadrada esta es la
fórmula de un binomio al cuadrado
perfecto y si éste fuese un binomio al
cuadrado perfecto entonces ya sabría
quién tiene que ser a quién tienen que
ser b y bueno nada me cuesta revisar si
de por casualidad
este si es un binomio cuadrado perfecto
4 t cuadrada tendría que ser a cuadrada
y bueno si esto pasa entonces tiene que
ser la raíz cuadrada de 4 de cuadrada
que es 2 t y ahora tengo que fijarme en
b cuadrada déjame ponerlo con otro color
de cuadrada tiene que ser 9 me estoy
fijando en esta fórmula que tengo aquí
me falta ver cuadrada y dos veces saben
de cuadrada es igual a 9 por lo tanto me
tendré que ser tres
lo único que estoy haciendo sacar raíz
cuadrada de 9 y entonces tengo que
revisar que aquí en medio en efecto me
quede dos veces el primero por el
segundo es decir 12 ts a dos veces ave
dos veces ave para que esto sea un
binomio al cuadrado perfecto así que
déjame escribirlo dos veces sabe tiene
que ser este por éste por dos así que lo
tengo que poner aquí abajo si de pura
casualidad
este es un binomio cuadrado perfecto
entonces este de aquí se tienen que ver
como dos veces a b es decir 12 te tienen
que ser 2 x 2 t por 3 2 x 2 tm de 4 t
por 3 me da en efecto 12 t y date cuenta
que si fuera menos 12 t alguno de estos
dos tendría que variar el signo a tendrá
que ser menos 2 t o en su dado caso b
tendría que valer menos 3 y bueno 12 t
ya vimos que si en efecto es el que está
aquí en medio por lo tanto toda esta
expresión es un binomio al cuadrado
perfecto todo esto lo podemos
simplificar y lo podemos factorizar de
la siguiente manera podemos escribir
+ b elevado al cuadrado es decir 2 t que
suma a 3
y todo esto elevado al cuadrado 2 t3
elevado al cuadrado es la factorización
de 4 t cuadrada más 12 temas 9 lo único
que utilice fue la fórmula del binomio
al cuadrado perfecto y claro no olvides
que aquí tenemos un -1 un -1 que
multiplicaba toda esta expresión y que
era nuestro factor común y esto es muy
fácil de recordar si tenemos un término
elevado al cuadrado y otro término
elevado al cuadrado y de pura casualidad
en medio tenemos dos veces el primero
puede segundo entonces es un binomio al
cuadrado perfecto